all right I'm really excited about jexy
so you play a guy whose life is taken
over by his phone right yeah are you
addicted to your phone in real life we
all are people don't try to hide it okay
I'm a real addict yeah well I think
everybody I don't know how to drive
anywhere oh if I don't get directions
from my phone I don't go there I know
and it drives my husband nuts he's like
why you use your phone you know what if
something happens in your phone you're
not gonna know where to go and I'm like
I'll find it ya won't find I like we'll
be on Queens I'm you two ways and then
like I won't be able to find my way home
yeah like literally I'm going home
I'm out of place where I know where I'm
at and then try to find my way home I'm
like I just got to punch it in two ways
what if I have to spend two and a half
more minutes more in the car I'd rather
take 11 left very dangerous left-hand
turns to get me to get there yeah do you
feel like you've switched from childhood
I feel like I new phone numbers I knew
addresses I knew I knew everything how
to get anywhere when I was a kid like on
my bike and like or walking whatever and
like now like as an adult I am now a
toddler who knows none of that
I don't know anyone's number I know I
know my husband I don't yeah I don't
really know anyway even my parents like
they don't even have a home phone and
it's why yeah no one does yeah and lines
are dead I know
archaic like it like the like bell the
bell company they're pissed Jeff Bell or
whoever that guy was he's bombed I don't
have a home phone is my mom and dad
right here by the way
[Applause]
so awesome with this one he's so loved
I literally no one has gotten that kind
of flawless yeah I paid him so it you
and your family recently you celebrated
Adam Devine day yeah yeah I I shot my my
Netflix special admirin vines best time
of our lives on one person so cool you
applause there but they gave me the
mayor gave me my own day in Omaha don't
get a key you'll get something better
than today well you know what I thought
it was a day every year I thought every
November 10th I'm getting it and I saw
some people Irie looked at the plaque
they gave me perform at the Emmy Awards
last month it was incredible but here's
the funny part of it is you got you're
under attack for like first of all the
greatest thing ever I was under attack
guys I was attacked well they variety
said that I lip synched which which by
the way it just means you're that bad oh
hey thank you for that but I sang I I
sang that and I was I was pretty bummed
no no that's happened to me before and I
was like I wanted to call this lady
named Lisa I feel like any I feel like
any real singer would have been like oh
no he's saying that you could you could
tell it was actually a good thing like I
was I would got so mad about it when it
happened to me like years ago cuz I was
like I just worked my tail off onstage
like and somebody said that and then
everybody was like well maybe it just
means you did it so well it would they
by the way if I'm ever asked to do
anything like that again I'm more than
happy to lip-sync that would take away
like all the pressure that's like it's
like a full day of rehearsal like the
day before and I'm just like trying to
learn like dance moves and I'm not a
real dancer or a singer so I'm like not
in my it's what makes it yeah you fell
that's the best yeah where where I feel
like me out there doing that it gives
like anyone
hope it's just a guy out there who's
mute all right well my favorite part was
the giant meryl streep head it was a
little psychotic and she had no soul cuz
the eyes were gone but the eyes were
dark yeah they were dark but weirdly
that was Meryl Streep doing that she
does everything she's also an amazing
juggler talented she's really talented
this is also something I find I found
out about you that I did not know so you
were in like a horrific accident when
you're a kid and it was a truck hit you
cement truck a bigger kind of truck
bigger even how did that shape you
because you've got to beat you you had
to mangled me yeah I was a very weird
shape after that weird angles I meant
like mentally and emotionally that's
like yeah yeah yeah yeah change things
you're sure well no absolutely I think
like yeah I I like em now I'm like happy
that had happened because I don't think
I'd be doing what I'm doing and it also
it like gave me the confidence that I
can cuz I had to relearn how to walk and
like I couldn't walk and it was a
two-year process so like gain the
strength back in my legs and learn how
to walk again and I lost all the muscle
and I'd shattered everything for my
knees down and so I had to like fully
relearn and that's like very hard to do
turns out and hey you think like on
paper you're like yeah one step another
step we got it
you figured it out when you were one you
could figure it out now but it was very
hard and so now I like I'm like I could
do anything when I can't but I have that
confidence but you can't that's what I
love about I think that a lot of like
creative people have odd things that
happen to them and how they're horrible
or whatever because it kind of shapes
unit make sure you this creative person
that you can you know make fun of
yourself like September occasionally
sure and even have like no shame or
probably just like I'm in it and also
like I feel like like my parents being
here what's up mom and dad and go on
them and they they also then were like
because I as a blue-collar family from
the Midwest like we didn't didn't know
anybody in Hollywood we didn't know that
you could even like truly make her
career out of this if that's what you
call this it's a career mom but they
then they got on board and they were
like they're like whatever you want to
do you didn't die yeah whatever you
wanted to you can be a doctor and a my
robotic to stand-up comedian and they're
like okay this question and I always
kind of start questioning myself later
on that day but what do you think if
that wouldn't have happened like do you
think that this would have been your
path or do you think you would have done
something else
for sure I would be like oh cool wedding
DJ and I would do a lot of radio edit I
want to go right to the like the good
part of the wedding is like the vows and
then people cry and then immediately
start drinking that's what I want my
wedding to that I eloped and was like by
II I'm gonna give everyone camelbaks
filled with wine or whatever type of
booths
so they could just suck their way
through the way you were you have to
sing know you do have to sing you were
you weren't a wedding singer though but
you did have an interesting job that we
actually have in common you were a
telemarketer oh you were a total marker
I was Oh dad I was a telemarketer for
the comedy club I cocktail waitress for
oh you did that so I got to kind of sell
them free tickets but there's a
two-drink minimum I did a lot of weird
I like sold time-life books over the
phone I sold steaks which mistakes is
where I worked yeah it would be a lot of
me is that like how do you how do you
sell that mine was easier I would call
and my main thing it's so stupid I would
take a piece of paper and this was like
my closer I would wiggle the piece of
paper in front of my face which is where
the headset was and and then I go sorry
excuse me my manager is here what's that
you know I can't really know what and
then I get back and I'm like I'm so
sorry I can't believe this is happening
but this just came in from upstairs the
one floor building this came in from
upstairs we're gonna cut the price of
those fillets my hat I can't believe
we're doing this and then you just say
now does that FISA start with a four
they all do yes
and what are those other numbers a 1 and
that paid for my 1993 Cavalier ya title
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going